la nièvre était jusque là presque une
exception dix neuf décès en hôpital a
déploré moins de 300 cases avéré le
département le moins touché de bourgogne
franche comté alors se retrouver classé
en zone rouge
l'annoncé a surpris un peu étonné par
rapport au nombre de cas dans la nièvre
et au nombre d'hospitalisations c'est un
peu étonnant que je sais pas comment ça
a été cette établi il reste aussi
attendre la date du 7 mai puisque là on
saura si déconfinement il y avoue pas
pour le 11 mai le plus étonnant une
première carte qui pointe si la
circulation active du virus
la nièvre est le seul département en
rouge de la région
l'épidémie n'est pourtant pas devenu
particulièrement virulente
j'ai pas de remonter effarante de
développement du coc vide avec les
infirmiers infirmières aussi est en
secteur hospitalier du groupement
spiteri thouars sa baisse donc c'est
vrai que c'est pas compréhensible d'être
nous le département en rouge
voilà l'idée c'est pas de se comparer
aux autres chacun sa peine dans tout cas
ça n'est pas logique
la situation serait due à une erreur de
chiffres des tests demandés par la rs
aurait été comptabilisés comme des
suspicions de qu'ovide mais un deuxième
critères entrent en compte la tension
hospitalière hélas alors que la nièvre
ne compte plus que quatre personnes en
réanimation
l'indicateur et régionales ce classement
se fait sur deux critères
quand un seul des critères et rouge le
département est rouge et le critère sur
la tension dans les services de
réanimation est un critère qui n'est pas
départementale mais régional donc
l'attention sur les services de
réanimation qui existe dans quasiment
tous les autres départements de la
bourgogne franche comté est répercutée
sur le département de la nièvre
si la nièvre pour est ainsi repassé en
verre sur l'un des critères il faudra
compter sur une baisse d hospitalisation
dans toute la grande région pour oublier
le rouge
verdict le 7 mai faute de quoi la
réouverture des collèges notamment
pourrait être repoussée